Speaker 1: Lawyers are increasingly predicting
that failed former President Donald Trump
is inevitably going to be indicted.
And we're going to look at one of those op
eds momentarily.
Now, there are many people asking if Trump
is indicted.
Is he going to be arrested and perp walk than
booked at a federal prison the way that many
so-called normal people are?
And I believe the answer is obviously not.
And we're going to get back to that in a moment.
But let's first start with the case that is
increasingly being made.
Very interesting article in The Daily Beast
by Brad Moss, who says it's over.
Trump will be indicted.
The case is as follows.
Brad Moss says Donald Trump will be indicted
by a federal grand jury and he believes that
the reason for that is as follows.
Number one, Trump was in unauthorized possession
of national defense information, namely, properly
marked classified documents.
Number two, Trump was put on notice by the
U.S. government that he was not permitted
to retain those documents at Mar a Lago.
And number three, Trump continued to maintain
possession of the documents and allegedly
undertook efforts to conceal them in different
places throughout the property up until the
FBI finally executed a search warrant earlier
this month.
And Moss says this is the ballgame, folks.
Absent some unforeseen change in factual or
legal circumstances, he believes there is
little left for the Justice Department to
do.
But to decide, do you indict before the midterms
or after the midterms in terms of what you
ask for the grand jury?
And as Moss also points out, the cruelest
irony for Trump is it never needed to be this
way.
And that's a theme with Donald Trump.
Much of the problems that Donald Trump gets
into, many of the problems are a result of
Trump's own doing and self-inflicted harm.
So let's now think this through.
If Trump is indicted, will he be arrested?
Book perp walk that a federal prison?
The answer is almost certainly not.
Donald Trump will almost certainly be given
the opportunity to present himself to the
FBI on his own terms.
And it's all going to be handled in a very
different way than it is with so-called mere
mortals.
And I use that term extraordinarily sarcastically.
Now, there is a counterpoint to that, which
is when you look at what Trump is being investigated
for, based on all of the documents that we
now have, when you're talking about Espionage
Act violations, you often don't give those
people a chance to turn themselves in.
You arrest them.
And that's an absolutely perfectly natural
analysis.
But it's Trump.
It's Trump.
And we have to set our expectations correctly.
The FBI and Secret Service would almost certainly
just coordinate the delivery of Trump to the
Justice Department.
Trump will probably be, by the way, I you
know, if and let's not get ahead of ourselves,
if and when this happens, it's going to be
a historic and historic moment.
It's going to be both in American history,
unquestionably.
And they will say it's unprecedented and that
means it's wrong.
Well, no, Trump did things.
No president did.
So now the outcomes are also different than
they were with any other president.
But.
Donald Trump is almost certainly going to
fundraise off of this if Donald Trump is indicted
and he's given some bail amount.
He is going to fundraise off of it.
It's going to be absolutely incredible to
see Donald Trump doing this.
So I think if we want to be as realistic as
possible, I would put out of your minds that
you're going to see Trump in an orange jumpsuit
behind bars.
I would bet anything I have that that's not
going to happen.
I'm with you that Trump and the people around
him who were complicit in what are now countless
instances of wrongdoing, they deserve to be
prosecuted.
And if found guilty in prison, there's no
doubt about it.
But even just think about it.
I mean, Trump in a federal prison, like even
if it was even if it was plausible that Trump
would be sentenced, it is a national security
risk to have a former president in a federal
prison.
It's an insane conversation that we're even
having.
But if I think ahead, five, six, seven, eight
steps and I think about if there are charges
and if there's a conviction or a plea deal
that involves some kind of serious consequence,
it's Trump restricted to one of his luxury
clubs, right?
I mean, I think we would all probably agree
that's the direction it goes.
But the big headline is not that that's speculative.
That's about the future.
The big headline is lawyers increasingly believe
Trump is going to be indicted.
And the growing question is, what exactly
is Donald Trump's legal defense going to be?
And that's what I want to talk about next